[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du 7 8 sociétés
ce rendez vous hebdomadaire où on
discute on échange et en débats sur des
sujets qui font l'actualité 5% de femmes
seulement sont lauréate d'un prix nobel
une seule femme et dirigeant d'une
fédération olympique et en 2016 83 bien
que j'aie % des élèves féminines devenez
baechler contre 60 contre 40 % de
garçons certaines yvelinoise se démarque
mais quelles sont leurs parcours en août
elles ont rencontré des difficultés on
en parle avec nos invités alexandra
bonetti bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
joueuses de golf professionnel vous vous
entraînez principalement dans les
yvelines
elodie incase bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
doctorante en kinésithérapie au
laboratoire sciences de l'université
paris saclay vous êtes notamment
lauréate d'un prix l'oréal unesco
origines et vous êtes aussi originaire
de chevreuse et fabien audi bonsoir
m'enfin vous êtes référent académique
égalité fille garçon pour l'académie de
versailles
alexandra je vais commencer avec vous
vous êtes donc joueuses de golf
professionnel c'est un métier qui vient
tout d'abord une passion
oui tout à fait donc j'ai commencé une
balle parce que mes parents jouaient
lorsque j'avais 17 ans et il avait
l'habitude de me les faits à la garderie
donc en moins chez les envies de j'ai eu
envie de les accompagner et d'essayer ce
sport qui m'a beaucoup plu je vais
garder d'autres sports
en complément jusqu'à mai 13 14 ans et à
partir de cet âge là c'est vraiment ce
sport que j'ai choisi de le peaufiner et
de m'engager totalement donc je suis
ravi
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous ai dit je
serai sportifs professionnels alors les
portes ça m'a vraiment toujours attiré
j'étais quelqu'un qui en école primaire
aimait bien jouer au foot
avec les gars courent dans les cours de
récré et suivait tous les sports à la
télé avec mon père des choses comme ça
donc ça le côté sport ça m'a toujours
marqué et le golf est un sport
individuel
moi qui suis fille unique c'était assez
proche de mon style devient aussi on va
dire ferme vraiment où j'ai pas besoin
de ne pas bouger toutes les cartes en
main en fait ou si je fais une erreur
c'est seulement de ma faut des choses
comme ça qu'ils m'ont beaucoup plu dans
ce sport et le dink est votre domaine
c'est la recherche ont quitté ces
thérapies qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à
vous lancer dans l'univers justement
scientifique
oui enfin le recherche en sciences du
mouvement du coup l'université ce qui
m'a poussé c'est surtout la volonté de
comprendre jeu très tôt était passionné
impressionné par le fonctionnement du
corps humain et les mécanismes
d'apprentissage et et donc quand j'ai
fait mes études de kinésithérapie à la
fin de mes études j'avais encore envie
d'apprendre des choses sur le corps
humain de comprendre plus de choses et
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu continuer
en recherche pour pour approfondir mes
connaissances
alors chaque semaine on interroge nos
téléspectateurs la question de la
semaine pensez vous que certaines
professions soit encore fermées aux
femmes et les téléspectateurs ont
répondu oui à la majorité elodie ou
alexandra est ce qu'à un moment vous
vous êtes dit que votre profession
n'était pas fait pour vous non pas par
rapport à vos capacités mais par rapport
à votre genre alexandre un petit âne aux
hoquets et bien moi c'est presque
inverse en fait parce qu'il y avait une
faune est un peu plus bâtiment excessif
dans le golf féminin avec un peu moins
de concurrence et donc une possibilité
de performer un peu plus facilement
entre
c'est toujours du sport de haut niveau
et c'est très compliqué de percer mais
par rapport aux circuits masculin où il
ya encore plus de concurrence ou chez
les femmes
si on se donne à fond et qu'on est très
rigoureuse
il ya beaucoup de chances que ça puisse
marcher et vous elodie alors moi je
dirais que je me suis pas sentie limitée
jusqu'à mon entrée en thèse par le fait
d'être une femme
toutefois je pense qu'il ya vraiment un
plafond de verre et qu' il est beaucoup
plus difficile pour les femmes d'accéder
à des postes à responsabilité à
l'université notamment par rapport à la
fait d'avoir des enfants et l état
actuel du congé maternité paternité mais
aussi pour plusieurs autres facteurs
mois après mois du coup j'ai été
encouragé par madame kris de thèse qui
elle même une femme et je qui a eu un
parcours très qui a eu son propre
parcours brillant en tant que femme donc
ça m'encourage beaucoup aussi à suivre
ses traces votre directrice de thèse
caroline taulier qui est maître de
conférences à l'université paris saclay
fabien audi à ce qu'en 2021 l'académie
de versailles doit encore sensibiliser
les élèves voir les parents sur le fait
que la profession qu'on veut faire et
pour tout le monde
vous avez raison les parcours scolaires
ils sont encore contrasté les filles et
les garçons continuent en fait à ce1 se
conformer à ce qui est présenté comme
leur domaine respectif de compétences
dans des schémas sociaux professionnels
encore fortement stéréotypé donc il ya
un travail académie qui est menée pour
promouvoir la mixité des filières et et
des métiers on a vraiment un rôle à
jouer donc un travail à mener avec les
enseignants et les élèves sont très
engagés aussi sur ces sujets surtout que
l'égalité commence dès la primaire en
fait on n'attend pas le collège pour
l'heureux pour l'orientation justement
non il ya des travaux effectivement il
ya une formation pour les enseignants du
second degré mais aussi une formation
pour les enseignants du premier degré
si on prend notamment les espaces les
espaces la cour de récréation voir
comment les espaces sont distribués
comment les filles et les garçons
occupent l'espace
donc il ya un vrai travail à mener et
aussi sur les pratiques professionnelles
les gestes professionnels qui sont
développées par les enseignants quel
type de deux tâches on va demander à un
fer au jeune fille ou au jeune garçon
observer ces pratiques professionnelles
et les des genres et et avoir une
pratique pédagogique éducative
égalitaire donc il ya un vrai travail à
mener et on poursuit ce travail en
académie
alexandra à seulement 15 ans vous vous
remporter une médaille de bronze aux
championnats d'europe
vous étiez invité sur cette compétition
comment vous l'avez vécu ce moment ça a
été un déclic pour vous avez fêté
clairement le déclic le moment où j'ai
décidé d'en faire mon métier de décider
que ça allait être mon métier parce que
je n'avais pas prévu passé pour tout de
suite
c'était vraiment inattendu car ce
tournoi et je n'aurais pas pu le faire
sans être membre de ce golf en fait donc
ils bloquent nationale dans l'est à
saint quentin en yvelines et comme
j'étais membre j'ai pu avoir une
invitation wild card a mis ça et je
finis 3e aux côtés de filles qui ont des
années de plus que moi qui quelques
années après sont parmi les meilleures
européennes voire mondiales
donc non ça m'a donné beaucoup de
confiance il m'a permis d'intégrer les
équipes de france et c'est génial
justement fabien audi des parcours comme
celui d'alexandra bonetti ou des
loadings keynes est ce que ce sont des
exemples à montrer justement dans les
établissements scolaires oui on a besoin
de personnalités inspirantes
on a même organisé
une master class dans l'académie à
destination des collégiens qui
s'appelait comment construire son projet
en dehors des stéréotypes et on a eu
claudie haigneré on a eu un sage femme
et puis des jeunes lycéennes et lycéens
dans des dans des parcours une jeune
fille en filière sti2d où il ya plus de
garçons que de filles et un jeune homme
en filière asp où il ya plus de jeunes
filles que de jeunes garçons et donc
pour montrer qu'il ya une mixité
possible dans les métiers dans les
filières et on aimerait organiser encore
plus de master class et c'est ce qui
s'est passé sur sur la journée du 8 mars
et sur toute la semaine où il ya des
rencontres avec des professionnels et
c'est très très important pour nous
voilà des personnalités inspirantes et
que les modèles soient soient multiples
et qu'ils aient une visibilité de tous
ces parcours très très important et très
riche très divers je voulais parler de
cette journée du 8 mars et sur twitter
on peut découvrir que de nombreux
établissements de l'académie ont près
ont partagé leur création il y à des
boîtes à mon image des portraits de
femmes exceptionnelles vous en avez
nommé quelques-unes des expositions est
ce que pour sensibiliser il faut aussi
faire participer
alors oui il faut faire participer donc
on a des référents égalité dans dans un
bon nombre d'établissements on a des
équipes qui sont engagés aussi je vous
le disais des des élèves engagés des
collégiens des lycéens engagés on a un
conseil académique à la vie lycéenne ou
vous avez un certain nombre d'élus qui
ont porté sur les territoires des
messages et des actions très
intéressante
on a vraiment eu un live instagram aussi
avec la directrice d'onu femmes france
lundi soir à destination des lycéens
donc on a vraiment un engagement de tout
et de tous et je tenais d'ailleurs allé
à les féliciter et le dinh keynes vous
parliez tout à l'heure d'un plafond de
verre aussi de la maternité qui est un
manque seules les femmes actuellement
peuvent connaître est ce que vous avez
ressenti très tôt on sait qu'en 2011
en france il n'y avait que 42 % de
filles qui étudie en l'étude
scientifique en s est ce que vous l'avez
ressenti très tôt vous ce ce changement
cette différence moi je n'ai pas
ressenti spécialement tôt surtout que
j'ai grandi avec une maman qui a dû
retravailler donc immature encouragés à
faire la même chose qui voiture expliqué
que c'était pareil pour les femmes par
contre j'ai commencé à m'interroger
beaucoup là dessus quand tu arrives et
en thèses parce que les postes
d'enseignant chercheur à l'université
sont assez rare c'est un milieu assez
compétitifs et donc il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de choix à faire en fait après
une thèse à faire des post doc à
l'étranger d être très mobile dans toute
la france pour espérer trouver un poste
et donc c'est plutôt sur ce type de
problématique
on s'interroge beaucoup en tant que
femme sur le moment dans lequel on va
caser un congé maternité enfin vraiment
ce dîner est ce qu'il y aura un bon
moment est-ce que la fin voilà est-ce
que ça va pas me freiner de d'avoir des
projets de maternité c'est vrai qu'on
sent que c'est des questions que se
posent énormément plus les femmes que
les hommes
moi je suis dans un milieu à
l'université en sciences du sport ou
c'est assez égalitaire enfin doctorant
en tout cas on est autant de femmes que
d'hommes
mais on sent que les femmes se posent
beaucoup plus de questions là dessus et
se sentent plus handicapé sur ces
questions a justement le sport alexandre
à votre corps et votre outil pour
travailler pour réaliser on sait que des
sportifs ont pu avoir des enfants mais
le retour sur la scène est difficile à
ce que vous même on a des idées
footballeuses qui ont mis un peu en
retrait leur envie d'être maman est ce
que vous l'avez ressentir 6 alors bye
justement quand elodie en parle et samia
fait penser parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
golf hausse qui donc ont dû faire une
pause grossesse mais il y en a un grand
pourcentage qui reviennent ensuite et je
suis vraiment admiratif parce que
le changement de corps et il y en a qui
jouent jusqu'à cinq mois de grossesse
enfin c'est hallucinant notamment une
française qui avait fait ça il ya
quelques années et elles reviennent et
est là pour le coup le fait d'être une
femme n'est pas un avantage parce qu'il
faut avoir la chance d'avoir un mari
très compréhensifs
parce qu'ensuite reprendre le chemin des
tournants à être en voyage constamment
si on n'a pas un bail qui peut s'occuper
un peu des enfants forcément la femme
doit décider de mettre fin à sa carrière
en fait c est en fait non fabien audi
disais tout à l'heure ils font aussi des
animations ils font rencontrer des
personnes qui ont réussi des thèmes
parfois des grands noms parce que
souvent pour se choisir un métier on a
besoin de modèles
elodie une keynes est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui vous a poussée au reproche
peut-être à vous lancer dans votre
doctorat notamment oui vraiment faim
elle du coup les deux personnes je vous
ai parlé un peu jusqu'à maintenant ma
maman qui m'a toujours encouragé à avoir
un métier en tant que femme et ma
directrice de tests que j'ai rencontrés
quand j'étais en master et avec qui on a
construit le projet de thèse et donc
voilà qui mature beaucoup encouragé qui
a ouvert les chemins pour que tout soit
rendue possible
ça vient on dit justement comment on
contacte les personnes pour les faire
leur expliquer qu'ils font montrer et
qu'on peut réussir quand on est une
femme
alors en fait on a des associations avec
lesquelles on travaille des associations
partenaires comme femmes et sciences
femmes et mathématiques
les intrépides de la tête pour le
numérique on a bien d'associations avec
des professionnels qui peuvent
intervenir
donc c'est une façon pour nous sur les
territoires de faire découvrir des
métiers et des personnes et on voit bien
en écoutant elodie alexandra que ces
rencontres elles sont importantes
donc il faut vraiment les développer
pour ouvrir le champ des possibles pour
nos élèves
vraiment c'est très très important et
j'invite les enseignants et toutes les
communautés éducatives allait solliciter
souvent les personnalités répondent
assez favorablement et assez facilement
elle aime partager donc c'est bien saint
seurin c'est à développer
vous disiez tout à l'heure que les
élèves sont aussi parfois dans un
blocage personnel mais c'est un blocage
qui vient d'eux ou qui vient souvent des
parents qui sont en fait la génération
avant en fait il ya un je pense que
c'est multifactoriel
il ya à la fois le dépassement de soi
l'univers dans lequel on est et puis
l'école aussi ce qu'elle va apporter
donc tous ces gens là doivent doivent
bouger pour que l'élève puisse
construire son propre projet et selon
les élèves et selon les contextes
on peut avoir différents bloquant mais
je pense que les bloquant peuvent être
plurielle alors on parlait des modèles
aussi quand on parle de golf on pense
principalement à tag à tiger woods par
non décidément je pense que c'est le
premier nom qui vient à l'esprit mais il
ya une golfeuse alors je m'excuse
d'avancé je ne prononce pas bien son
prénom son nom de famille annika
sorenstam c'est une 80 c'est 90
victoires professionnelles dix tournois
majeurs alexandra c'est un exemple pour
vous oui moi j'ai même encore une photo
d'elle et moi quand je suis allé la voir
quand j'avais une dizaine d'années sur
un des tournois majeurs ah et bien j'ai
fait et qui a eu lieu sur le sol
français et c'était une idole est là
d'ailleurs c'est bien que vous en
parliez pas ce qu'elle a refait surface
car elle a eu 50 ans tout récemment et
elle va pouvoir jouer le senior tour en
fait et pour un peu se préparer à
l'ambiance de la compétition elle a
disputé un tournoi du circuit féminin
normal est et elle a passé le cut donc
le cut
il représente le top 60 des joueuses
parmi un champ de 140 joueurs en fait
donc elle a déjà battu le 92 ans sans
avoir fait de compétition depuis une
dizaine d'années c'est incroyable et de
dean cain je disais en début d'émission
en 2020 vous recevez un prix l'oréal
unesco jeunes talents pour votre test
sur vos recherches
le fonctionnement de la marche du tout
petit les femmes sont peu récompensée 1
je disais au début 5% seulement eu un
prix nobel
un prix comme celui de l'oréal unesco
c'est bienvenu puisqu'il ne récompense
que des femmes
oui moi je pense vraiment que
effectivement il faut passer par ce
genre de dispositif pour s'assurer que
les femmes autant d'opportunités que les
dom
c'est vrai que des choix c'est parfois
c'est un petit peu critiqué bas par les
hommes qui ne peuvent pas participer à
ces essais pour cela mais mais voilà
maintenant que en tant que femme en tout
cas c'est très encourageant de savoir
que kylie a comme ça des dispositifs est
pour nous encourager et qui n'ont plus
la main l'occurrence ces bourses elle me
permet aussi d'acheter du matériel pour
poursuivre mes recherches
donc vraiment quelque chose qui
encourage nos carrières etc
c'est très appréciable ou bien sûr mais
justement 2021 c'est la thèse qui doit
être présentée tout se passe bien
oui oui tout se passe bien là je devrais
normalement rendre ma thèse d'ici un
mois ou deux croit en durban donc là
présenté cet été
donc on sait ça fait plaisir que ça
touche un petit peu à sa fin pour
boucler quelque chose et est ensuite
barre à poursuivre femmes dans ces
domaines de recherche l'armée mais bon
quand même passé un peu à autre chose
fabien vous dire on le voit on a deux
univers qui sont parfois très masculin
la science le sport
il y a aussi le 17 mars prochain les
jeudis de la recherche avec un thème
femmes et numérique
le numérique c'est un monde où il faut
encore peut-être pousser les filles
en fait les femmes étaient étaient
d'ailleurs très très présente dans le
numérique au début et puis on les
retrouve moins dans des enseignements de
spécialité
donc il ya un vrai travail à faire
auprès des jeunes filles des rencontres
des témoignages et puis des stages
immersif dès le collège donc il faut
effectivement être sur une politique
assez volontariste pour pour aller vers
une mixité des métiers
alors il ya bien entendu des enjeux pour
les filles mais il ya aussi des enjeux
pour les garçons on a des filières aussi
très masculinisés donc il ya un travail
aussi pour les féminiser pour les rendre
mixte et inversement il ya vraiment des
enjeux pour les chi et pour les gars et
vous le disiez tout à l'heure le métier
de sage-femme
on a souvent l'habitude de voir des
femmes mais les hommes peuvent le faire
exactement et c'était assez surprenant
pour nos collégiens quand tu construis
laurenceau qui intervient à ubs qu
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines et quand il a présenté son
métier et il se définit d'ailleurs comme
un sage femme et il a expliqué son
métier et ses essais des rencontres
comme celles ci qui sont très
importantes des femmes des hommes plus
ou moins célèbres mais en tout cas des
parcours divers variés riches qui sont
pas forcément rectiligne aussi ça c'est
important de voir qu'il ya des étapes
dans les parcours et qu'on peut passer
d'une filière à une autre et ces
rencontres qui peuvent aider à passer
d'un d'une filière à une autre
j'entendais elodie qui a eu ses
rencontres ou même alexandra s'est point
d'étape important ces bilans et ses
avancées dans les parcours alexandra
qu'est ce que vous diriez à une jeune
fille qui se voit peut-être un jour jose
de golf professionnel ce que les
golfeuses ne représentent que 25% des
joueurs tous niveaux confondus en france
il ya 118 me les licenciées féminines
quel serait le conseil que vous
donneriez 1 2
ne pas se limiter dans ses rêves et ses
objectifs car le la pire des choses
c'est le regret en fait donc il vaut
mieux essayer s'entourer des bonnes
personnes et ensuite y aller et voilà
jusqu'où on peut aller en fait mais
effectivement ne pas hésiter de demander
de l'aide à des personnes qui sont déjà
passés par le même cursus ou mellal par
exemple la fédération française de golf
a fait quelque chose de très bien parce
qu'elle a demandé à une ancienne joueuse
française qui a été numéro 1 européenne
d'encadrer un peu le pôle france des
filles des jeunes filles qui ont 18 ans
à peu près et dans tout de suite lançant
il ya une nouvelle dynamique parce que
les jeunes filles elles sont tout de
suite un peu plus aller coûte quand
quelqu'un d'un calibre comme ça là lors
des mes conseils et vous et load inc
haynes quelques conseils vous donneriez
une jeune femme qui veut se lancer dans
la recherche voile évidemment je lui
dirais de foncer enfin comme disait
alexandre à tout à l'heure je pense
qu'il n'y a pas que des désavantages à
être une femme
c'est vrai que il ya certaines choses
qui soient encore frais matrix mais
comme la société s'est rendu compte de
toutes ces choses là et dernièrement il
ya beaucoup de dispositifs bas comme la
bourse l'oréal dont on parlait ou les
dispositifs dont parlait fabien qui
encourage la la réussite des femmes et
donc ça peut parfois être un atout on
voit maintenant des postes qui sont
orientés pour vers les femmes pour
assurer que dans les entreprises ou ou
dans les universités on atteigne certain
quota l'université il ya aussi beaucoup
de par exemple pour la soutenance de
thèse il faut absolument qu'il ait même
nombre d'hommes que de femmes dans le
jury
pour s'assurer que justement de plus en
plus de femmes atteignent des postes à
responsabilité dans la recherche donc
voilà je le redirai vraiment de fond
c'est parce que je pense que ça va aller
que on s'arrange laurentienne problème
là fabien audi je vous ai vu acquiescé à
plusieurs reprises quand alexandra
bonetti et le dim keynes disaient de
foncer
c'est aussi le sentiment que vous voulez
partager aux élèves de l'académie de
versailles
oui oui je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'elles ont dit et c'est
important d'avoir ces propos là de leur
dire d'y aller ce sera pas toujours
évident mais il y aura toujours des
personnes sur le parcours qui pourront
les accompagner les aider et des
rencontres donc oui foncé n'ayez pas de
regret oui
ouvrez vous les horizons et les univers
plus poussif je vous propose de terminer
sur ces mots c'est une société
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau moment de
discussion prenez soin de vous
[Musique]